hi there today we'll look at playing
Atari with deep reinforcement learning
by Vladimir Mooney at a love deep mind
so this is another one of our series of
impactful past papers this paper right
here kicked off an entire revolution in
reinforcement learning specifically it
sort of started the deep reinforcement
learning hype before that I
reinforcement learning was kind of this
weird field of Markov decision processes
and so on now I know there were
successes and all and stuff was
happening but this really made a lot of
waves because it brought the power of
deep neural networks to reinforcement
learning and with a pretty simple
application of convolutional networks
managed to solve these reinforcement
learning games where previous algorithms
really couldn't either or were heavily
reliant on hand engineered features so
we'll take a look here and what what
people did back then what was the state
of the art and what they are telling us
about that kind of setting in relation
to today all right if you do like papers
like this
commentary like this share it out leave
a like and tell me in the comments what
you think so let's dive in they say we
present the first deep learning model to
successfully learn control policies
directly from high dimensional sensory
input using reinforcement learning the
model is a convolutional neural network
trained with a variant of Q learning
whose input is raw pixels and whose
output is a volume function estimating
future rewards we apply our method to
seven Atari 2600 games from the arcade
learning environment with no adjustment
of the architecture or learning
algorithm we find that it outperforms
all approaches on six of the games and
surpasses a human expert on three of
them so there's a lot packed into this
first of all I want to recognize the
absolute laughs tech-savvy
jury right here it's here yeah you know
it's just just something I'm not I'm not
obviously about that kind of stuff I
think we should ditch a lot of tech
honestly but so there's a lot of
information packed in this abstract
right here so they say this is the first
deep learning model to learn control
policies so that's the task of these
reinforcement learning algorithms
directly from high dimensional sensory
inputs using using reinforcement
learning so what do they mean this are
called learning environment if you don't
know what it is it's basically these old
games right here you can kind of emulate
them and run them and the inputs are
always sort of the same so you have one
joystick I believe so you have a kind of
this joystick and you can go into
various directions like left-right
up-down and then also the intermediate
directions and then you have a I think
also a button that you can push and that
gives you a total of some somewhere
around sixteen or twenty actions in each
of the game so the good thing about this
environment is that the actions are
always the same but of course they mean
different things in different games so
the games here you know for example pong
or this breakout these games are kind of
really low pixel games as you can see
and they come in form of an image right
so this is an image this is like 180
pixels and this is like 150 pixels and
the task here is to learn a policy which
means which buttons and directions you
need to push depending on the
observation right here
these pixels and achieve the maximum
amount of reward
so reward is given in each game
differently as well for example in this
pong game the reward is every time you
score kind of a goal against your
opponent in breakout you get a reward
every time you manage to hit or kill a
one of these blocks and so on so a
reward is different but your objective
is always to maximize the reward
in in a formal framework you have an
agent and an environment and the
environment would always give you an
observation which in this case the
observation is one of these images and
the agent will give back an action so
the action in this case would be the
which button to press or which direction
to move the joystick into and then the
environment would get back give back a
reward so the reward is could be you
know it could be this you score the goal
so that's zero most of the time and
sometimes it's one or or nine or it
could be like how long you're alive and
so on this is very very very variable so
the difficulty of reinforcement learning
very often is that these episodes can go
for a while so this whole process here
will repeat over time and the this can
go on for hundreds of steps or thousands
of steps until you're done you know
playing a game like this like this right
here and the reward can be very sparse
so you might only get a reward at the
very end of the game sometimes most
often in these games you get one in
between but still there can be multiple
time steps where you don't have a reward
and your task is to figure out which of
the actions were the good ones this is
known as the credit assignment problem
and to do the credit assignment problem
just from pixels alone that was unheard
of at the time this paper came out
that's why they say we are the first
deep learning model to successfully
learn the directly from high dimensional
sensory input okay so the power of deep
learning they argue is that a deep
neural network a convolutional neural
network can extract these high-level
features by itself however at this time
people only knew that it could do so for
supervised learning basically for every
input of an image you had a label and
and that's how you
these convolutional neural network here
it's very different here you'll get
maybe a thousand of those images and you
simply say well you got a score of 1100
and somehow we need to figure out which
ones of these were the ones that gave
you the good score and how to generalize
that so there are various difficulties
here to apply convolutional neural
networks to this problem and they have
detail right here how they did it so
they say the model is a convolutional
neural network which you know have been
demonstrated so this is after things
like Alex net though before ResNet
trained with a variant of q-learning
whose input is raw pixels and whose
output is a value function estimating
the future so we'll get into q-learning
hew learning is a reinforcement learning
algorithm that has been around you know
for a long time but just not combined
with deep neural networks and yeah then
they say the last cool thing here is
that they apply them to seven games with
no adjustment of the architecture or
learning algorithm so that they apply
the same algorithm the same hyper
parameters to all of the seven games and
the model learns all of the seven games
not as a single model but as seven
different models however they all have
the same hyper parameters so they don't
need to do tune them which is an
additional benefit like this would have
been a cool paper even if they had to
sort of tune the algorithm to each of
the seven games but you know they didn't
which makes it even more impressive it's
kind of their point here that these that
this reinforcement deep reinforcement
learning can be some sort of a general
learning mechanism of course you know
later there has been like giant amount
of development since this and people
have come up with all kinds of giant
architectures and whatever Corrections
of policy Corrections seem to real
continuous control this is this is most
of it is a derivation of the
work right here and this work it reads
surprisingly simple I have to say and
it's almost like they had little idea
what problems were to to be tackled
later in RL because it kind of reads
like you know we have this thing and you
can learn general things so yeah that
was we're still not done with
reinforcement learning I I guess we
we've just started okay so in a bit more
formal setting what you'll have in
reinforcement learning or these rewards
right so at each time step you perform
and actually you're in a state so the we
said you get back an observation and we
call the observation the state now these
two things aren't a sorry these two
things aren't entirely the same thing so
the observation is what you get back
directly from the environment and then
the state it can be something more like
if you remember something from the last
observation that can be part of your
state the state is basically what you
base your decision on and the
observation is the pure thing you get
from the environment now in this case
they do some processing but essentially
will will regard them as the same thing
so the state is what you see of the
environment then in each of these steps
you perform an action we'll call that
this a thing right here and in each step
you also get a reward for the last
action that you took and the reward is
going to be lower case or now what you
want to do formally is you want to
maximize the reward that you get in time
T sorry you want that's the reward you
get at time T prime you what you want to
do if you play an episode with you're
here and you perform an action you go
here perform an action you go here you
perform an action you go here and then
your episode is done for each action
you'll get a reward reward one reward to
River three what you want to do is you
want to maximize the total the sum
all of these rewards so over the course
of your episode you want to collect as
much reward as you can there is a
discount factor right here which is sort
of saying that rewards that are very far
in the future they're not as important
as rewards right now however you can set
this to one if you want so you see you
want to maximize the future the sum of
future rewards which is this thing right
here okay
so how do you how do you do this there
are two main methods in reinforcement
learning the the first one is called a
policy gradient method and very briefly
a policy we'll call it PI takes in a
state s and it gives you back an action
ok and I mean this is the same for for Q
learning but in a policy gradient method
which is not this paper but it's like a
little bit easier to understand I
believe will simply say well we'll
simply train a neural network to do that
right and there is this um there's this
policy gradient trick where you can back
propagate even though the reward isn't
you know back propagate table and so on
you example say we'll learn a neural
network to give us the action that's
best right so we'll have a neural
network the state goes in neural network
and then we'll just have as many outputs
as there are actions like action 1
action - action 3 action 4 and we'll
treat it as a classification problem
right so you simply train the network to
pick the action that is best in this
case and you up irregardless of how you
know which action is best right now
in Q learning you do something else
namely you train this thing called the Q
function the Q function is a function
that takes in a state and an action and
it gives you what the reward is going to
be in the future if you are in this
state and perform this action ok so you
are in a given state right and you have
three actions at your
okay you have action one action - and
action three and you are in state s you
what you would do is you would call the
Q function if you had a perfect Q
function it could give you the reward
you would call the Q function three
times you would call the Q function
first with a 1x a what's Q of s and a
one and the Q function would maybe say
that's seven and here you say what's the
Q function of s and a two and it will
maybe say that's four and here the same
thing for a three and it maybe say
that's one then you would know aha if I
take action one my reward from not only
the reward for this step but my reward
from here on until the end of the
episode is going to be seven that is if
you had a perfect q function now the Q
function is always of course conditioned
on a policy right here so there is work
but it basically says it I take action
a1 right now and after that I follow
policy PI then I'm going to get the
reward of seven it's a bit of a
multi-layered reasoning approach but
ultimately you don't have to you don't
have to worry much about this being this
being conditioned on a policy ultimately
the Q function says if you take this
action right now what will the reward be
for the entire rest of the episode okay
so if you had a perfect Q function you
could simply ask it about all the
actions as we did here and then pick the
action with the highest number okay and
then you're guaranteed because you know
there could be a situation where you
know you're your reward in a single step
is going to be very high here like a
hundred and here zero zero okay and you
would be tempted to take that action
right here but but after that it's just
going to be zero zero zero so your total
reward is going to be 100 but here even
though it's zero now it could be that
after that it's 50 and then 40 and
then mm and so on so your total reward
is going to be much much more if you
were simply to train a function that
tell you what's the reward in the next
step then you would lose because that
function would not be able to look ahead
sufficiently what we're trying to do
with the cue function is we're trying to
predict to train a function that will
tell us not only what's the reward in
the next step but what is the reward in
all the steps to come from here right of
course conditioned on all the decision
we make in the future but that's this
policy pie
right here I hope it's somewhat clear
what the Q function is interestingly we
can take the same network architecture
for this so what you would do naively is
you would build a neural network where
you say okay my Q function takes the
state and an action so I'll put those
into a neural network and then out comes
this estimation of the reward which we
usually call Q so that the value Q is
this estimation of the future reward if
you take this action in this state now
the the disadvantage here is that we
have to call this neural network once
for each action in every state that
we're in so that's like if there's ten
actions that's like ten forward passes
what we could do is we could simply take
the same neural network we had for our
initial or very initial policy method
and we use that and we simply input the
state and we'll train it to output the Q
for action one and the Q sorry for the
state s and action one the Q for the
state s and action two and so on so
there is going to be this kind of shared
encoder and then that is basically going
to encode the state into a latent space
and then classify for each of the
actions how valuable this particular
action would be in that state so the
this here is called a deep Q Network
okay it's a network that takes in a
state and gives you back the Q value now
the problem right here is
we you know here we said if we had a
perfect q function a q function that was
always right and then the problem would
be solved because we could just ask the
Q function what to do of course we don't
have a perfect hue function we need to
train it so how do we train a Q function
and the answer is surprisingly simple so
what you want to do is you want you are
in this you're in this state and you
want to estimate right what your Q value
is you want to train your Q Network what
you can do is you can simply play an
episode according to the Q function you
have and you maybe play this episode
right here right like you go here and
you collect all of this reward so this
entire thing now goes into your data set
and then you have a sample you know I
was here in this state s I took action 1
and I got in total 2009 T as a reward so
that is going to be a labeled sample
right your labeled sample is going to be
s I was an S I did a 1 and now I have
identical 2090 reward qu and in the next
episode so you're going on playing and
you maybe go down here and then you get
a next training example I was in state s
I so you keep restarting the episode so
you can get into the same state multiple
times I performed a three and I got only
100 reward so that's another training
samples of these training samples right
here you can use to train your Q
function this is called online
reinforcement learning you play the game
at the same time as you train your
neural network and you use that improve
neural network to play more games and
with time there is this well-known there
is a there are theorems around Q
learning that say if you do that
iteratively then your Q function will
converge to the optimal Q functions
under some assumptions which are of
course not given if this is a deep
neural network but you know who cares
yeah so formally
your cue function as you can see right
here is going to be there is this
bellman recurrence kind of recurrence
property of the cue function so if I am
if I am in a state s and I'm wondering
what is my Q of my state s and my and an
action a and I said with respect to a
policy which the star policy is going to
be the policy where we always select the
highest Q function so we'll basically
say we're in state s we select action a
and after that we'll just always select
whatever the highest-scoring action is
right like right now
action a might not be the highest
scoring but we'll take a right now and
after that the highest scoring that's Q
star it's a Q function conditioned on
the policy where after we perform the
first action which is a will take always
the best one according to the Q function
right that's right here so we're in
state s we perform a and s prime is
going to be the state that we are going
to so we're in s we perform a we get to
s prime so in s prime which is a
function of your environment we're
always going to take the maximum action
and R is going to be the reward of the
next step so you can see this recurrence
equation right here that Q star can be
framed in terms of Q star so the Q star
of this state is going to depend on the
Q star of the next state and you can use
that fact and you can you know prove
that pretty we've already done it
basically you can use that fact to now
train your neural network so your neural
network loss function is going to be the
following it's going to say look this
here is the Q function for state s and
action a that's my and this is my neural
network telling me how much that's worth
and this is the label right so here you
have to think in terms of back classic
supervision supervised learning this
here is going to be your f of X
and this here is going to be your why
and we will take the squared loss
between the two accept your input X is
going to be which state am I in and
which action am I taking and your label
is going to be bootstrapped
by your own Q function so your label is
going to be the reward you got remember
this comes from a replay buffer we
already played that game and we already
know what happened after we perform this
action right and what happened is we got
this reward and we got into this state
so we can simply ask our own q function
again what's the best action to take in
this state and what reward would we get
and then we have our label right so our
label y is going to be yeah I was I was
I was pretty confused when I learned
this the first time so I'm going to
assume some of you are confused as well
so your q function is supposed to tell
you what's going to be the reward from
here until the end of the episode okay
that you can decompose in the reward
that you get from this very next action
plus the sum from then so T plus one
until the end of the episode okay so our
t prime so that's T prime equals T plus
one all right so it's it pretty simple
the total reward from now until the end
you can decompose in the reward now plus
the reward after that until the end now
this here we know we've played the
episode we know what happened this here
we can simply ask our q function again
because we also know what state we got
into and this as you can see is very
much this but just one step later so we
can simply ask our own q function which
might be imperfect right but it's
certainly a good guess we say okay this
reward from now should be equal to the
reward we go
Plus whatever we reward we get later and
yes you might be astounded by the fact
that we are using our own neural network
though v8 with the parameters one time
step ago in order to produce our label
but that is exactly what these
q-learning theorems are about they
basically say under some assumptions if
you do this and you iterate then this
will converge to the optimal q function
so as you can see right here this is the
this is the gradient of the loss it's
astounding that back then they still
wrote down the gradient of the loss like
almost no one does this now you just say
and put this into tensor flow and go
yeah so they make some remarks here
namely that this algorithm is model free
right that there's no model of the
environment you simply learn a function
that for each state tells you the Q
value for each action that's that's all
everything everything that the other
logic needs to be within the neural
network itself so that's pretty cool and
they say it's also off policy it learns
about the greedy strategy while
following a behavior distribution that
ensures adequate exploration in the
state space so while while training they
do this epsilon greedy strategy that
follows the greedy strategy which is
where you always take the maximum with
one minus Epsilon selects a random
action with probability Epsilon so while
you do your experience you follow your Q
function you always ask the q function
what's the best thing to do right here
but you know that's that gets you into
too much of exploitation
so in epsilon amount of time you want to
do a bit of exploration and just take a
random action all right so that's
basically the algorithm so the algorithm
is right here and they have some tricks
to get it to work and the biggest trick
they got it to work is the so called
replay buffer this experience replay
because what happens if you play a game
of
hary right of palm specifically then you
know you have this and you're here and
your opponent is here and the ball is
here and then the next frame you are
here again your opponent might be a bit
up and the ball is here okay and so on
so these samples here they are all very
very correlated right the ones after
another especially if you now build
mini-batch let's say or mini batch sizes
to this mini batch has almost no
variability in it so if we felt with
something like batch norm or whatnot
this this will be like terrible because
these data samples are correlated and we
in supervised learning we make a pretty
big deal out of you know shuffling our
data set and all the data points being
iid and so on so what they say is rather
than using the data samples as we
collect them we put them into a big big
buffer a big replay buffer and from that
replay buffer we basically sample at
random okay so that means that you know
some samples can be used multiple times
other samples can be never sampled
because there is a fixed size and the
new ones will always kick out the oldest
ones so some samples might not be used
some samples might be used twice or
three times we can also learn you know
four times as fast as we sample and then
every sample on average will be used for
time so this this experience replay
proved very very important for this
algorithm to work that's why they say
deep cue learning with experience replay
so they have this replay memory D right
here to capacity M and you initialize
your cue function with random weights as
you do with a neural network and then
you play these episodes for each episode
you start out with s 1 the state 1 and
you do pre processing so in pre process
they have some more tricks where they
downscale the image they concatenate
four images in a row because sometimes
in authorities flicker things and also
if you concatenate four things in a row
you
example can tell it within which
direction the ball is moving and so on
so give a little bit of history so one
sample technically would be four frames
they also do sticky actions and so on
all of these things that you can find
today in these emulators that are almost
default now like sticky actions they
invented right here so for the time
steps within the episode we want to
weave probability epsilon select a
random action otherwise just ask your q
function what should I do right here
give me the best action in this
particular state then you would execute
that action and observe a reward and the
next state so the next image right here
you would set the next state to this
transition okay so in the state there
can be more as I said there can be more
than the image like the previous state
and the action you took but right here I
believe it's purely the current last
four frames and then you store that
transition in the replay buffer after
that you sample a random mini batch of
transitions from the replay buffer so
here you can see this here is where we D
correlate the inputs because if we
simply were to use our last transition
for learning then we would run into a
problem but right here we sample from
that replay buffer so this is going to
be your input this is going to be your X
for your supervised learning of the deep
neural network what's going to be your
sorry
without the reward of course what's
going to be your Y your Y if you're at
the end of the episode it's simply the
reward that you got because there's no
more reward coming however if you're not
at the end it's the reward that you got
from this last step plus all of the
reward that you're going to get in the
future now you aren't in the future yet
but you can ask yourself you can ask
your q function what that reward is most
likely going to be if your q function
gets better
and this estimate gets better and your
labels get better than your cue function
gets better and so on in a big circle
and then you perform a gradient descent
step on this l2 loss between the label
and your prediction note that there if
you are in a deep learning framework
there is like a stop gradient on this
label right here so the backpropagation
only happens with respect to this right
here which makes sense right so this is
your X this is your input and f of X is
usually what we back propagate into okay
there's no notion yet of like a second Q
network and so on which proved very
valuable in the future of this paper
this paper simply applied kind of the
most basic version of this and they
simply got it to work
they just got deep neural networks to
work with reinforcement learning and
yeah there's a big a big chance that
this was due to this experience replay
which I believe they did not invent I
mean the the this has of course around
been around before but they were the
ones to realize and combine and do that
it's also pretty interesting the neural
network that they actually used was like
super duper small the input to the
neural network consists of 84 by eighty
four by four image produced by this so
this is the pre-processing at the first
hidden layer convolved 16 8 by 8 filters
with stride for with the input image and
applies the rectifier and non-linearity
so the relu the second hidden layer
convolved 32 4x4 filters was tried to
again followed by rectifier
non-linearity the final layer hidden
layer is fully connected and consists of
256 rectifier units the output layer is
a fully connected linear layer with
single output for each valid action
number of valid actions is varied
between 4 and 18 on the games we
considered ok so you can see that neural
network is pretty small it's too complex
and as was in fashion back then you had
like big filters so you know big filters
from like Alex net you had big filters
but fewer than today
so today the trend is more like deeper
layers more filters but they are not as
big they're like three by three filters
today only
yeah pretty interesting how they did it
back then interesting also no max
pooling and so on pretty cool and here
they go into experiments so they show
that their average reward in these games
is kind of noisy but it improves over
time especially also if you look at the
average cue of the max action it
continuously goes up during training so
this is really a successful training
especially this investigative experiment
they did right here where you can see
one example of how the cue function what
the cue function says remember the cue
function gives us the whatever the
future reward is going to be okay and
here we always look at the max action so
in this first frame you can see this
enemy had just appeared and you can see
that from here to here there's a spike
in the Q value because you can shoot
enemies and that gives you reward the a
this is already so the enemy isn't shot
yet by the simple appearance of the
enemy the Q function also like already
jumps in value because it anticipates a
future reward then the D agent shoots
and you can see here the shot is about
to land at the enemy and that's when
we're here so this now the Q function is
very sure that in the future there's
going to be a high reward but then once
the once the enemy is shot then there is
no more enemy to be shot and the Q
function drops drastically because it
doesn't see a future reward as being as
likely as at the beginning when there
was this new enemy too
shot so that's you know pretty
interesting and you can see pretty
directly that there is a correlation
between what's happening in the game and
this learned cue function if you compare
this to other methods and they really
say that these other methods most of
them have some kind of very special
feature engineered like so their method
just takes RGB but the other methods
recognize that own these Atari games
most of the time you know there are
unique colors for the things so you know
the enemies are all like green like and
they make unique channels for those
green enemies or they even have
handcrafted object detectors and tell
the algorithm where these objects are so
the comparison really isn't fair yet the
dqn outperform these others like almost
everywhere and they also evaluated
against a against a human and I don't
actually know they just say an expert
human I have no idea maybe just put
David silver in front of computers like
okay David here you go and you can you
can like what happened in pong like come
on David but you can see there there
were still problems where the humans
were vastly superior and they mainly
attribute this to the difficulty of the
problem and it could also be because for
example in breakout them in this there's
this kind of the most famous example
where the agent kind of figured out this
strategy of shooting the ball
shooting like a hole into this wall that
you have to break and then shooting the
ball up here so the ball bounces up and
down and basically you win
from then on you just watch the ball go
and the agent does nothing anymore so
this deep queue networks figured out
that strategy and you need to pull it
off very precisely which of course the
the computer can do very well so it
sometimes achieves these super high
scores by pulling something off
precisely but in games where
they say where you have to plan ahead
for a longer it it kind of fails and we
know that this long planning was about
to be a problem for years to come and
it's still not solved so still a go
explorer is highly controversial that
can solve these kind of long exploration
games and those are still games right so
we are basically not we are very much
further than they were in this paper but
also we are basically no nowhere yet
yeah if I'm if I'm allowed to say that
so I enjoyed reading this paper I this
is it's very it's very well written if
you somehow know how to think about
reinforcement learning like this this
cue function what the Q function means
and why you would learn it in this way I
find that this is not super well
described this kind of requires a bit of
a knowledge of not of RL but just of how
to think of RL but apart from this
everything else is written incredibly
well easy straightforward and you know
this was just a nice work of its time
and I appreciate it for that all right
I'll see you next time and I appreciate
your time - bye